[Musica]
no
come sapete la parola chiave di questa
giornata e desiderio
io l'ho scoperto qualche mese fa quando
ricevuto l'invito alta ed ex putignano e
sbirciando nel file della presentazione
ho visto questa parola desiderio
riportata a caratteri cubitali
nel testo del invece era poi scritto che
desiderare può essere inteso come
sentire il bisogno di colmare una
distanza quando ho letto questa
descrizione ho pensato immediatamente
alle distanze incolmabili quelle che mi
riguardano direttamente ma quelle che in
realtà riguardano tutti noi perché non
sempre possiamo soddisfare i nostri
desideri
a volte ai desideri sono materialmente
impossibile
ma il concetto di impossibile relativo e
la realtà materiale solamente una tra le
varie realtà per cui è lecito porsi un
quesito
esiste un modo per soddisfare i desideri
materialmente impossibile
e la domanda che mi sono posto anch'io
nella 2020 quando mi accingevo lasciare
il mondo normale per trascorrere un anno
nell'ambiente più estremo del pianeta
laddove la distanza tra nei principali
oggetti del desiderio sarebbe stata
incolmabile
questo posto dell'altopiano antartico un
nuovo che somiglia più a marte che la
terra la temperatura scende sotto il
meno 80 gradi centigradi l'aria è secca
si fatica a respirare ritmi circadiani
sono alterati
il sole non sorge per cento giorni di
fila lasciando al buio un paesaggio
spettrale inanimato bianco e piatto in
ogni direzione siano all'orizzonte
eppure in questo enorme deserto di
ghiaccio dove non prolifera alcuna forma
di vita nemmeno virus e batteri l'essere
umano quindi noi ci siamo azzardati a
realizzare una stazione di ricerca
scientifica chiamata concordia
si tratta di una base situata sopra uno
strato di ghiaccio spesso 3000 metri
distante dalla costa più di mille
chilometri
era la china cingevano andare per la
seconda volta avrei trascorso un anno
assieme a 11 persone essere mostrati più
isolati al mondo i raggiungibili da
febbraio a novembre nove mesi senza
possibilità di essere soccorsi
l'agenzia spaziale europea avrebbe
approfittato di questa particolare
condizione per compiere su di noi degli
studi di biologia umana per capire come
il corpo si adatta ad un ambiente
sostanzialmente extraterrestre al fine
di pianificare al meglio una una futura
missione su marte
e cosa mi succederà mi son chiesto prima
di partire cosa mi succederà quando nel
bel mezzo della lunga notte durante la
spedizione avrò il desiderio di ripetere
mia moglie andare al mare o stare sotto
il sole
desideri materialmente impossibile come
quelli di un carcerato di chi per vari
motivi non può stare con i propri cari
con non può evadere da un determinato
ambiente per vagare liberamente in altri
posti
cosa mi succederà nessuno quindi chiesto
perché in effetti come già accade quando
non possiamo soddisfare un desiderio
perché materialmente impossibile
tipicamente accade che soffriamo e
soffriamo tanto più intensamente quanto
è più intenso il desiderio può cadere
anche dell'altro forse il desiderio
influenza il nostro inconscio forse la
nostra mente tenta di alleviare questa
sofferenza cercando di soddisfare il
desiderio in un'altra realtà quella del
sogno come in parte sosteneva floyd ma
queste sono solamente ipotesi perché il
meccanismo è la funzione di sogni a
tutt'oggi rimangono ancora un mistero
e comunque sia anche se un carcerato
sognasse di evadere dal carcere
probabilmente al risveglio avrebbe
ancora il desiderio di scappare forse
anche più di prima
e questo accade per vari motivi in
primis perché la memoria del sogno per
la maggior parte delle persone molto
volatile a risveglio dimentichiamo
rapidamente ciò che abbiamo sognato e lo
strascico di sensazioni ed emozioni
causate dal sogno si affievolisce sino a
sparire completamente con ci immergiamo
nello stato di veglia
ma anche se fossimo in grado di fare dei
sogni vividi quando questa realtà è
capace di lasciarci ricordi duraturi
probabilmente non saremmo in grado di
soddisfare in sogno
perché non abbiamo il controllo del
sogno in particolare di due aspetti del
sogno la frequenza è il contesto
adesso vedo di chiedergli meglio
partendo dalla dalla frequenza
consideriamo ancora nel caso di un
carcerato che vuoi andare al mare o
quello di una persona qualsiasi che vuoi
avere una relazione amorosa
materialmente impossibile con
chicchessia
entrambi possono sognare queste cose ma
non hanno alcun controllo sulla
frequenza con cui sognarle può darsi che
nessuno una volta al mese o magari una
volta all'anno mentre invece magari
vorrebbero sognare più spesso quando
invece dico che non abbiamo alcun
controllo sulla frequente sul contesto
intendo dire che non abbiamo il
controllo sull'atmosfera del sogno
sull'ambientazione il carcerato potrebbe
anche sognare di trovarsi al mare in un
incubo però mentre annega tra le onde e
quindi al risveglio non sentirebbe di
certo soddisfatto il suo desiderio
sembra quindi impossibile soddisfare in
sogni i nostri desideri
anche perché vivere in sogno una
esperienza è ben diverso che vive la
nella realtà ed è comprensibile che se è
così perché questi due stati lo stato
del sogno è quello del sonno e quello
della veglia sono ben distinti
normalmente sono non sovrapponibili
cosa accadrebbe però se fossimo in grado
di sognare e al contempo essere
coscienti ovvero cosa accadrebbe se
fossimo in grado di sognare la
desiderata relazione amorosa mentre
viviamo in uno stato in cui il sogno e
la veglia sono sovrapposti e coesistono
simultaneamente
soffriamo di poterlo fare quindi
immaginiamo di poter sognare questa
relazione mentre siamo in questo stato e
in più di poter controllare anche la
frequenza quindi stabilire quando fare
questo sogno e anche il contesto come ad
esempio l'ambientazione tranquilla di
una spiaggia o quello di una casa in
questo caso saremmo in grado di
soddisfare il nostro desiderio in tutto
anche in parte
per poter rispondere a queste domande
dobbiamo procedere per gradi
chiedendoci innanzitutto è possibile
fare questo esiste uno stato in cui il
sogno e la veglia sono sovrapposti è
possibile sognare essere contempo
coscienti in secondo luogo se questo
fosse possibile sarebbe anche possibile
controllare la frequenza è il contesto
di questo tipo di sogni
queste sono domande importanti
se consideriamo che ci interessiamo noi
come mani a questi gli argomenti da
qualche migliaio d'anni almeno il
fenomeno del sogno cosciente infatti era
ben noto in oriente e tramandato per
secoli sino ai giorni dolce perché
faceva parte di alcune pratiche logiche
ma anche ai filosofi o incidentali anno
interessate a questi temi tant'è che
aristotele nel trattato si sogni scrisse
che spesso quando siamo addormentati
c'è qualcosa nella nostra coscienza che
ci dice che stiamo sognando
abbiamo però atteso la metà del 1800 per
dare un nome a questo stato di coscienza
non ordinario chiamandolo sogno lucido
sempre in questo periodo quindi nella
seconda metà del 1800 mentre la
rivoluzione scientifica avanzava a vele
spiegate
abbiamo scoperto che la nostra attività
cerebrale così come quella di altre
specie da luogo a flebili segnali
elettrici nella corteccia le cosiddette
onde cerebrali
abbiamo poi scoperto che queste onde
celebrali differiscono a seconda che ci
troviamo uno stato di sonno o di veglia
a quel punto di alcuni studiosi è venuto
in mente di fare un esperimento
monitorare e registrare le onde
celebrali di soggetti che dichiaravano
di poter fare dei sogni lucidi con il
successo che il 12 aprile del
1975 nei laboratori della hull
university è stata dimostrata
scientificamente l'esistenza di questo
stato di coscienza in un ordinario
chiamato sogno lucido
oggi quindi sappiamo che è possibile
vivere in una realtà in cui il sogno e
la veglia coesistono simultaneamente e
sono sovrapposti
adesso facciamo un passo avanti vogliamo
cercare di capire se è possibile
e a controllare la frequenza il contesto
di questo tipo di sogni perché magari
vogliamo appunto soddisfare in sogno i
nostri desideri
gli oniro nauti ovvero coloro che sono
in grado di fare sul mi lucidi
sostengono che si può
io però sono una persona tendenzialmente
diffidente così nella nell'autunno del
ho voluto verificarlo di persona e si
trattava di un impresa ardua perché al
tempo non ero in grado neppure di
ricordare i sogni o comunque voluto
intraprendere queste pratiche con
testardaggine le ha portate avanti per
diversi diversi mesi senza ottenere
alcun risultato però con ancora più
testardaggine o incrementato la dose ha
deciso di andare in india per pulire
ripulire la mente con lo yoga e
dedicarmi unicamente a queste pratiche
così in india finalmente arrivato il
primo sogno lucido caesar dato di
un'esperienza che ha confermato ciò che
sino ad allora avevo sentito dire in
proposito
e mi son ritrovato in una realtà
talmente illusoria che mi è parsa
credibile quanto questa un mondo
talmente vivido che sembra tangibile
come quello in cui ci troviamo adesso
pensate che in questo mondo è talmente
difficile capire dove ci si trovi ovvero
se siamo svegli lo stiamo sognando e per
poterlo scoprire bisogna utilizzare
delle tecniche delle strategie ai
cosiddetti reality check in questo è
incredibile
se avete visto il film inception
probabilmente sapete di cosa sto
parlando
comunque sia al rientro dall'india
entusiasta da questa prima esperienza da
ognuno nauta ho voluto continuare la
pratica per incrementare la frequenza e
cambiare il contesto del sogno quindi
l'ambientazione i personaggi ho avuto in
media un sogno lucido al mese e poi
quando sono stato contattato per
partecipare alla mia seconda spedizione
a concordia
allora mi è venuta in mente mire ho
pensato realtà ero anche un po di paura
e quindi mi è venuta in mente questa
idea forse durante la spedizione
durante la lunga notte polare posso
tentare posso provare a soddisfare i
desideri ma ti lamenti impossibili il
culo in sogno lucido ho pensato che se
la cosa ci fosse dimostrata vera allora
anche altri avrebbero potuto usufruire
di queste tecniche ad esempio gli
astronauti nelle future missioni
interplanetarie o chi in generale
dovesse trovarsi in condizioni analoghe
a quelle di concordia ma in realtà il
discorso potrebbe essere ancora più in
generale perché tutti forse avrebbero
potuto approfittare di queste tecniche
allora ho pensato di contattare martin
dress nel curry e il direttore dei
laboratori di ricerca olandese che
studia la memoria e il sonno e si occupa
anche di sogni lucidi e gli ho esposto
la mia idea nelle intenzioni e lui si è
dimostrato da subito entusiasta ne ha
messo a supporto un membro del suo team
che ha predisposto dei questionari che
avrei dovuto compilare quotidianamente a
concordia ma non solo nonostante
mancassero solamente due settimane alla
partenza per l'antartide è riuscito a
farmi pervenire la strumentazione per
monitorare i movimenti oculari e le onde
cerebrali durante il sonno sono così
partito per concordia
entusiasta voglioso di portare avanti
questo esperimento ma anche curioso di
sapere se in realtà avrei soddisfatto mi
desideri materialmente impossibile la
concordia ma ben presto
sono andati incontro l'inconveniente e
la strumentazione fornitami da martin
era piuttosto invasiva mi costringeva a
stare ferro con una sola posizione
durante il sonno è un disagio che in un
ambiente normale può anche essere
tollerato ma l'altro piena antartico e
l'opposto di un ambiente normale
pensate che dello studio dell'agenzia
spaziale europea ha condotto su di noi a
concordia il risultato che la concordia
si va in apnea del sonno mediamente una
volta al minuto e le fasi del sonno sono
alterate quindi il sonno e turbolento e
agitato e complicato e difficile e degli
elettori sulla testa aggravano
ulteriormente la situazione quindi alla
fine ho desistito ma l'idea è ancora
viva e spero che questo tolgo possa
invogliare dei gruppi di ricerca e i
misti gare sull'argomento d'altronde la
per la posta in gioco è alta perché si
sogni lucidi si dimostrassero uno
strumento efficace per soddisfare i
desideri materialmente impossibili ma
anche semplicemente per
cambiare l'umore delle persone
migliorandolo allora tutti potrebbero
beneficiarne non solamente gli
astronauti o chi dovesse trovarsi in una
condizione analogo a quella mia
concordia e tra l'altro il futuro è
roseo perché l'univo nautica sta
diventando un argomento popolare
e'così gruppi di ricerca e aziende
stanno sviluppando dei dispositivi che
potrebbero stimolare il sogno lucido e
questo sarebbe un bel passo avanti
perché significa che si potrebbe
aumentare la frequenza e poi facilitare
anche esperimenti come quello che ho
tentato a concordia
ma a prescindere dall esperimento spero
di avervi incuriosito è invogliato
approva le sue luci non me lo auguro
perché leo niro nautica a un importante
risvolto positivo costringerà essere
attenti osservatori di questa realtà più
presenti e concentrati e questo è vero
indipendentemente da riuscire o meno ad
avere sogni lucidi perché il solo fatto
di provarci aiuta a ridurre gli
automatismi indotti dalla vita frenetica
e automatismi quelli che ci ostacolano
introspezione quelli che ci fanno
sembrare degli autunni privi di
autocoscienza addormentati mentre siamo
svegli e chi di voi riuscire ad avere
qualche sogno lucido forse andrà anche
oltre sino al punto in cui questo
risveglio onirico lo porterà a
riflettere profondamente sul senso della
sua esistenza facendo insinuare un
dubbio che questa vita sia semplicemente
un sogno che il termine risveglio in
fondo non necessiti di complicate
spiegazioni e con questo dubbio vi
saluto ringraziandovi per l'ascolto
[Applauso]
[Musica]